the nightmare
dating is so bad
oh it's so bad um
it's hard you know like
like we call
people civilians if you're not in the
business of civilians
um
don't like that i have a lot of
they don't like that it makes guys very
uncomfortable and
um it makes them
very insecure i mean i have sex with
huge
like big like like this like like this
is what i do every day
i mean
i don't think it's about is security per
se well there's some of that so there's
some of that for some people
another part of it is just like
i'm with you we committed to each other
if your job involved you having
emotional relationships other people
probably wouldn't be down with that
either not because
i'm insecure
we together
that's all it comes down to you know
sometimes people
you wouldn't let your girl have a only
fans you're insecure i'm not insecure i
just don't find it
attractive or endearing with my
partner's private parts all over the
internet i wouldn't want the same for me
do you know what i'm saying yeah
so is it hard i mean listen
just the fact that you refer to regular
people as civilians yeah i bet it is
hard that's how much of a different
world you live in because the only other
people i know who do that are people in
the armed forces and let me tell you i'd
probably recommend they don't date them
either
oh your significant other's on
deployment half the year oh you guys
gotta move basis and displace your
children all the time not the most ideal
lifestyle no you guys that's why they
get divorced and that's why they single
a lot and that's why they cheat a lot
more than the regular population in both
in both cases you are using your body
and
you you're like you're using your body a
lot and sometimes it can affect your
mind yeah both cases it's not for
everybody are you saying that the
military yes i said what i said okay you
heard what you were just back it up and
listen again listen if you think i'm
cabin ask people in the military they'll
tell you like yeah they're in the
military person most people in the
military wouldn't want their kids to
need somebody in the military
i'm not saying it's not possible i'm not
even putting them on the same level i'm
just saying they're in the same category
just different degrees i 100 would
recommend dating an adult star and i
probably like you know 60 wouldn't
recommend dating a
military person so a guy that's like six
inches which is totally fine and which
feels amazing he's like but i'm not that
guy yeah like i said which is totally
fine
when she did it she rolled her eyes like
she always has to give that speech yes
which is totally fine like
you're [ __ ] regular six inches
it's totally fine but she does have to
give that speech all the time
all the time bro that's for sure yeah
yeah because you know imagine this [ __ ]
again you know what i mean yeah yeah
yeah
or maybe six inches like whatever man
what make do like [ __ ] whatever it was
just funny because you'll see these
girls you'll be banging them you're like
oh man my girl loves me [ __ ] then you
get watched her pipe down by mandigo
making screams you never heard before
and [ __ ] with you i mean the [ __ ] would
hurt but it [ __ ] with you yeah i mean
it [ __ ] with her while it [ __ ] with
you yeah yeah you know what i mean
whatever yeah yeah what happens if one
of them [ __ ] at work pop was like yo
does your girl moan like this when she
i don't endorse boy but as an adult if
you were to bully someone imagine making
that [ __ ] your ringtone you just hanging
around the person your phone go off and
[Music]
you like that kylie
[Music]
you know i'm not man well
yeah and it's just irritating and i
i understand it i'm compassionate of it
it's very hard to date someone that has
every single day with other people
um and there's the jealousy factor
there's this dui size up factor there's
the idea that all of your friends have
seen me naked and seen me with things
inside me
you know that's not going to go away
there's always going to be my holes on
the internet and for something in a
serious relationship that's very very
hard for someone to cope with
oh there's something funny about that
sentence
my holes will always be on the internet
and she's right
there's also the fact of you have to get
tested
all the time because if you cheat on me
as much as i trust you you can cost me
my job
if you go do something and then i pass
out to set that makes me a horrible
human being so like so now i'm asking my
boyfriend or girlfriend to get tested
regularly because i'm trying to be
responsible but they're taking it as i
don't trust you you know
so there's that issue and then so you're
like okay well then i'm not going to
date a civilian because that's a [ __ ]
headache
um i'm gonna date a performer oh that's
a good idea let's see the performer
cause they get me right because they're
in the same industry and they get no
no
no
[Laughter]
two guys in this industry i love them
both very very much to this day nothing
bad to say about them it does not
[ __ ] work rarely it does and it's
fantastic um dana vespoli said something
awesome the other day on set that stuck
with me that said like it works if you
have the same goals
like you have mark wood and francesca
lay which are very very they're a very
very successful couple they have similar
goals you know manuel and cayden
you know happily married
um six you know similar goals
i have not been so lucky
it's hard to do a performer because
we're jealous we are all [ __ ] each
other like imagine going to a school and
having sex with everyone in that school
and then trying to date people that are
in that school but they just your friend
yesterday
imagine college
for some people
can you appreciate
can you appreciate this whole thing
her dating performer she sees them
[ __ ] everybody she gets jealous how
do you think civilians get
when they see you [ __ ] yeah i
appreciated that yeah
but the only difference they don't get
to [ __ ] everybody they're supposed to be
loyal to you and get tested but they get
none of the upsides you know what that
means no you don't you know what that
makes you
a civilian
you out here getting just like yo when
he piped me down i'll send him back home
he didn't do me how do you think the
[ __ ] civilian sees yeah when he sees
you with a [ __ ] loch ness monster
over there
making all kinds of noise that he didn't
even know existed in the lexicon
there's just an irony there yeah how
about they don't work because they're
jealous they're jealous
so so so dating people people can get
jealous okay good
carry on you know we all are going to
dinner but you know my boyfriend
last night it doesn't matter how
respectable you are and how much you
take your job seriously like you will
still get jealous
it's very very hard to not get jealous
so then you can go well i don't want you
to work with that person well i don't
want you to work with that person
because that's your ex-boyfriend well i
don't want to work with that person
because you know you one night and so it
becomes this very toxic she literally
sounds like what i imagine a civilian
dating a prawn star would sound like
absolutely
absolutely but she's making the ex yeah
maybe that's just my my suspicion is
that like these women who are in these
adult industries who end up dating
regular dudes traditionally end up
dating dudes who are cucks
that's been my personal perspective
generally on these people so it's like
it's tough it's a very hard thing to do
i'm not saying it never works it's just
very rare that it
does so dating is um
doesn't really happen
her and her dad
just kidding that's her boyfriend
[Laughter]
never listen yo your significant other
is your business i never read that there
was just something hilarious when i was
just looking some stuff up
no no there was just something hilarious
when i was looking this stuff up
and i was just thinking this [ __ ] to
myself
and i look up and i was like oh that's a
picture i heard her dad then i thought
that's her mate and something about bald
white dude just screams cuck doesn't it
like i feel like i've seen this same
white dude in a lot of videos just
sitting in the corner
what the
the
the thing that i have
bo white who's always been the one
that's been angry at me for some things
that i don't know what you mean i just
been jealous here some [ __ ] like that or
whatever over a girl that you didn't
touch like i don't even know the girls
calm down yeah but she's looking at you
like well you deal that with her i work
here sir gold
whatever like what like [ __ ] yeah
there's always been ball man hey ma man
ball man with goatees
[Laughter]
yeah
i'm all white dude with goatees
it's always been the one getting me
attitude for some [ __ ] i don't even know
about
anyways everybody got they think i ain't
getting everybody got anything which i
thought
it's not it's not it's not it's not a
thing to me like it doesn't
i don't think necessarily people would
be like cucks or whatever and not what i
date a performer i don't know
i don't i've seen enough adult videos
it's normally a bald white dude sitting
in the corner
i know because sometimes they don't even
let you into a cooking video they just
be smashing a girl and then a pen is
over this is like
honey do you like that oh he loves you
so much better than i can i'm like damn
why [ __ ] why am i still hard this is
weird but anyways
let us know but i couldn't date a
performer no shame on it if you can
shout outs to you if you can handle that
stuff that's cool i have everybody got
things
but i could understand
why people can't do it i can understand
why people wouldn't date a performer any
kind of performance i'm talking about
whether it's in that industry or whether
it's in any industry music [ __ ]
dancing [ __ ] comedy i understand
you're dating a performer
there could be a lot any kind of
performer to me
same thing different level
well let us know what you guys think in
the comments below we want to hear from
you
what do you guys think